ahead of the divisions launched this
week of reddit user has managed to mine
the game's files to reveal among other
things that the third person shooter
will offer at least twenty six missions
out of the gate I'm Kate and welcome to
this gamespot news update redditor it's
gamer doc says they stayed up for 21
hours straight to mind the game's data
files for interesting info and has said
that they have found pretty much all of
the missions another item that came out
of the data mining leak was a reference
to mission set in Brooklyn this borough
was shown off in earlier demos of the
division but is not included for launch
it's listing in the leak follows
Ubisoft's admission that brooklyn-based
content could come to the division as
DLC sometime down the road Ubisoft will
support the division with free content
in April and May well-paid expansions
are coming in the summer the data mining
effort also turned up vehicles such as a
water plane and a machine gun outfitted
helicopter as well as a hundred and
thirty-nine total weapons not counting
mods the division officially launches
tomorrow tuesday march eight are you
excited to play let me know in the
comments or come and find me on twitter
at how not to draw reviews will not be
available at launch but keep checking
back with gamespot for coverage of the
game this week and beyond